welcome to the property investors
youtube channel which i believe to be
the richest raw rest' and realist
property investors resource on the whole
of the internet every single Monday at 7
p.m. I'm gonna be doing a mentoring
Monday video and between 7 & 8 p.m.
every single Monday
I personally am going to be commenting
and responding to all the questions that
you have on mentoring Mondays Wednesdays
we have winners on a Wednesday every
week at 7 p.m. I'm gonna be bringing
onto the show my success students and
they're going to be revealing in depth
through interview exactly how they're
succeeding in property with new
strategies and cutting-edge techniques
I'm also going to be producing a video
every single Friday as well at 7 p.m.
the first Friday of the month is going
to be me out on the road buying live
property deals second Friday of the
month is going to be deep dive
discussions where I bring in experts to
discuss particular property topics third
Friday of the month you're gonna see me
filmed coaching my students one-on-one
accelerated coaching for Friday the
month is going to be a invitation to you
to come and attend some of our training
programs it's gonna be a show real and
the 5th Friday of the month there's not
that many fifth fridays but when there
is it's gonna be me giving you a kick up
the ass making you take action and
implement the stuff that you've been
learning throughout the rest of the year
so if you're a property investor or on
your journey to financial freedom
my suggestion is get some popcorn hit
subscribe and join the family
[Music]